bonjour m terminons ce cas l'émission
qui parle de livres qui parlent de
sciences humaines comme j'ai précisé
lors du premier épisode on va essayer de
revenir au fil des émissions sur les
philosophes les concepts qui ont marqué
le notre compréhension de la société et
des individus alors évidemment c'est je
pose mon regard sur ces concepts et sur
ces philosophes mais il est possible que
je me trompe complètement donc n'hésitez
pas à me reprendre ou à débattre de ces
concepts là dans les commentaires pour
ce second épisode on va s'attaquer à une
idée qui est très forte qui est
passionnante et que vous allez voir est
très actuelle il du panoptique par
michel foucault
bon
donc michel foucault est né le 15
octobre 1926 et il est mort le 25 juin
1984 qui va naître dans une famille de
notables à poitiers il va avoir une
scolarité qui va être assez irrégulière
dans la mesure où d'un côté il va avoir
des très bons résultats en maternelle
brillant et l'autre côté à s'est
dissipée finalement il va friser avec le
redoublement plusieurs fois après un
départ vers paris et un court passage au
lycée henri iv en 1946 en fait il va
intégrer l'école normale supérieure de
la rue d'ulm à ce moment là il va avoir
des résultats plutôt bons mais il va
avoir des gros problèmes avec ses
camarades la mesure où il va se friter
plusieurs fois avec eux
-bon dire que c'est un mégalomane et en
fait il va finir par se faire détester
d'absolument tout sa promotion
un mal être qui va l'amener à une
première tentative de suicide en 1948
d'ailleurs il dira aussi ensuite que
c'est aussi son homosexualité qu'il
avait du mal à gérer qui l'a poussé vers
ses extrémités là comment il était
vraiment épouvantablement difficile de
vivre son homosexualité dans ces années
d'un facebook où a vécu ça dans la honte
et dans le temps la faute d'enjeu dans
le drame et les tentatives de suicide
fin de la tentative de suicide en tout
cas le médecin de l'école normale me l'a
expliqué comme ça sans vouloir me donner
de détails puisqu'il ya le secret
médical vous fassiez l'explication qu'il
donne il arrive cependant à se remettre
au travail et il a passé son agrégation
de philosophie
en 1950 il va échouer ça va l'amener à
il seconde tentative de suicide
puis il arrive cette fois ci à se
remettre au boulot assez rapidement et
en 51
il parvient à obtenir l'agréation
philosophie il devient dès lors un
professeur de psychologie à l'école
normale supérieure et ensuite il va
enchaîner les expériences universitaire
et l'espérance de vie ce qui va l'amener
finalement à écrire deux oeuvres
majeures à savoir dans un premier temps
les mots et les choses qui est une
réflexion sur l'utilisation des mots et
des représentations au sein de notre
société et un deuxième ouvrage qui
s'appelle histoire de la folie à l'âge
classique où il revient sur la façon
dont considérer ce ponton perçoit les
fous ou plus considèrent comme fou dans
nos sociétés puis arrive mai 68 et lors
de la contestation
à ce moment là en fait michel foucault
va intégrer l'université expérimental de
vincennes en fait ces universités
assez particulière dans la mesure où on
fait sauter un petit peu les hiérarchies
les règles à la manière vont finalement
là essayer de le faire mais 68 et donc
en fait c'est aussi à un moment où on va
dire que les profs seront à équité avec
les élèves que la parole est libre où on
peut dire un peu ce que l'on veut et on
n'avait pas besoin du bac pour aller
danser est finie la cité donc c'est
vraiment une nouvelle façon de concevoir
l'enseignement et ce qui plaît bien
finalement un michel foucault qui a un
regard finalement très critique sur ce
qu'est l'enseignement et ce qu'est le
savoir dans nos sociétés que la première
chose qu'on devrait apprendre si ça a un
sens d'apprendre quelque chose comme ça
c'est que le savoir est tout de même
profondément liée au plaisir enfin qu'il
y a
kylie a certainement une façon
d'érotiser le savoir de rendre le savoir
hautement hautement agréable et ça que
l'enseignement ne soit pas capable même
de révéler cela que l'enseignement est
presque pour fonction de montrer combien
le savoir est déplaisant triste gris peu
érotique
moi je trouve que c'est un tour de force
mais ce tour de force il a certainement
sa raison d'être il faudrait savoir
pourquoi est ce que notre société a
tellement d'intérêt a montré que le
savoir y triste peut-être précisément à
cause du nombre de gens qui sont exclues
de ce savoir faire partie de cette
université pour michel foucault a été
très important et ça a été très marquant
c'est aussi ce qui va l'amener à
s'engager façon politiques et
associatives c'est à ce moment là qui va
former le groupe d'information sur les
prisons où j'ai ip donc le groupe
d'information sur les prisons c'est un
groupe que michel foucault va fonder
avec leurs oceanes est en fait c'est un
groupe qui va se charger de
mettre en exergue les abus et
potentiellement le dysfonctionnement du
monde carcéral et c'est à ce moment là
où michel foucault va mener une
réflexion sur la prison et les concepts
de la surveillance et de la punition
dans la société française et donc c'est
à ce moment là qui va reprendre l'idée
du panneautique alors là panoptique sait
quoi en fait à la base la panoptique
c'est un modèle d'architecturé carcérale
qui va être inventée par jeremy bentham
qui est un philosophe britannique du
xviiie siècle
en fait le panoptique c'est une idée de
l' architecture qui se base sur un
concept simple c'est à dire qu'on a un
avenir à bord qui va se situer au milieu
de la prison et toute la prison va être
construite en cercle autour de ce
mirador
si bien que les gardes dans le mirador
peuvent voir tous les prisonniers et
toutes les cellules en même temps et les
prisonniers ne savent pas vraiment à
quel moment ils sont épiés ou non ce qui
fait qu'en fait ils ont l'impression
d'être épié en permanence et ce qui
selon jeremy bentham est un bon moyen de
garder les prisonniers tranquille et de
les obliger à suivre les règles en
permanence ce qui va se passer c'est que
fout quoi va reprendre ce modèle l'
architecture et cette idée du panoptique
pour exprimer la surveillance dans notre
société est en fait il va dire que l'
usine que les lieux de travail dans
général qu'est l'hôpital que l'école
sont autant de tours de garde et de
cellules qui vont permettre à la société
d'analysé de décrypter les individus les
surveillants commun la chose
intéressante que foucault évoque c'est
que dans nos sociétés et dans
l'allégorie de la panne optique il n'ya
pas les r en fait qui est un gardien il
est juste nécessaire que les gens qui
sont surveillés et le sentiment qu'ils
peuvent être surveillés et que les
possibles que dans ce mirador iard
gardien est en fait dans nos sociétés
c'est la même chose c'est-à-dire qu'il
pas forcément obligatoire qui a un
policier à chaque crue pour qu'on se
comporte d'une certaine façon c'est
juste la possibilité qu'il y ait un
policier ou la possibilité que les
autres nous surveille pour qu'on s'y est
tranquille et finalement qu'on respecte
les règles de notre société est en fait
cela pour deux raisons
en premier lieu parce qu'en fait on
et contraint par des règles au sein de
notre société c'est la pause dans une
usine l'après midi ça dure 15 minutes
il faut pas mâcher du chewing-gum en
classe bref différentes règles qui fait
que si on les respecte pas on s'expose
au risque d'être éjecté ses institutions
et être éjecté du système social dans
lequel on est inclus en second lieu
parce qu on est tout le temps soumis à
la visibilité des autres c'est à dire
que on a en nous des règles des normes
qui sont très ancrés dans nos dans nos
individualités et on sait très bien que
on a tendance à objectiver à regarder
d'une façon différente quelqu'un qui ne
va pas respecté les règles et donc en
fait l'idée du panoptique par foucault
c'est qu'on est chacun un mirador qui va
observer chacun des individus et les
contraindre à se comporter d'une
certaine façon et toutes ces
individualités là vont être finalement
régi par la capacité des individus à
surveiller l'autre et à le faire
respecter les normes qu'on a toutes plus
ou moins négocier au sein du social je
vais dire est ce que les le pouvoir de
normalisation les techniques de
normalisation ne sont pas à l'heure
actuelle une sorte d'instrument général
que vous trouvez un peu partout dans
l'institution scolaire dans
l'institution pénale dans dans les
ateliers dans les usines dans les
administrations comme sortes
d'instruments général est généralement
accepté parce que scientifique qui va
permettre de dominer et d'assujettir des
individus là encore l'idée n'est pas de
dire que ce constat il est absolu
égalitaire on n'est pas surveillée de la
même façon selon
l'endroit où l'on travaille selon
l'activité qu'on exerce selon les selon
le le cercle familial dans lequel on
évolue cependant en fait le fait est que
on est tous régie et on a tous
intériorisé d'énormes façon très intense
et que chacune de ces normes va
s'exercer dans le regard qu'on va porter
sur l'autre et foucault dit de ce fait
qu on est dans une société qu'ils
appellent une société disciplinaire où
chacun des individus est régi par des
règles et que chacun des individus et à
la fois soumis à ces règles est à la
fois pas portée dans son regard dans sa
façon de scruter le comportement des
autres cette autorité et cette
discipline aujourd'hui ce concept de la
panne optique est particulièrement
intéressant et particulièrement actuel
parce qu'il ya un élément qui est arrivé
que foucault n'a pas plus justement
décrypter ces internet en fait sur
internet
ce set panoptique et cette vision
panoramique des individus elle est
constante dans la mesure où par exemple
netflix va regarder nos consommations de
visuels google va regarder par gmail
notamment ce qu'on tape dans nos mails
ou ce comptable dans son moteur de
recherche et amazon va nous suggérer
différents achats afin de motiver et
d'une certaine façon nous aurons
toutefois il faut pas tomber dans la
paranoïa c'est à dire ça c'est pas des
individus isolés de leur ordinateur qui
regarde nos moindres faits et gestes
cependant ce des algorithmes qui vont
des chiffres et qui vont essayer de
comprendre nos actions et qu'ils vont
essayer d'en dégager des schémas et ses
schémas vous permettent d'asseoir la
position le contrôle de d'amazon google
netflix sur certains pans de notre
fonctionnement social il est également à
noter que la surveillance panoptique à
l'ère du numérique elle et elle tend
également à dépasser juste nos
comportements derrière l'écran et
notamment par certains certaines
pratiques et notamment hubert en fait
libère c'est le fait de noter le
chauffeur le fait de noter le passage et
c'est autant de surveillance croisé qui
vont là s'exprimer encore une fois par
une note et donc du coup également par
un algorithme et donc chacune de nos
actions qui vont être décryptés par
l'algorithme votre ton de surveillance
qui vont être posées sur nos normes et
ont plus la chose d'intéressant avec
hubert c'est que on opte le pat riley
que les passagers sur noter est que les
chauffeurs sont de fait et donc à la et
ce qui nous a apporté une bouteille
d'eau ou est-ce qu'il a été sympa est ce
qu'il a été
à l'heure c'est pas et bien en fait tous
ces éléments là on va les pensées avec
nos normes c'est à dire qu'est ce qui
est pour toi qu'est-ce qui a trop
ponctuelles tous ces normes la con à
intérioriser et en fait on va poser avec
ça une note chiffrée qui va s'incorporer
dans un fonctionnement et ce
fonctionnement là il va être déterminant
dans ce qui est dans skins surveillance
de chaque individu une surveillante
croisée de chaque individu
voilà pour préliminaire
encore être plus vigilant sur la
surveillance croisé qu'on exerce et sur
les différents schémas que nous impose
la le numérique et les schémas sociaux
pour se prémunir de cette surveillance
et pour essayer de ne pas faire peser
sur les autres les normes qu'on a
intériorisé en fait il me semble qu'il
ya deux mouvements à faire le premier
mouvement c'est d'effectuer un un regard
critique sur nos normes c'est à dire
d'où elles viennent
en quoi elles sont légitimes peut
également laisser regarder une distance
avec le numérique
bon évidemment on court on a un
téléphone portable ou quand un
ordinateur portable
c'est impossible de s'en prémunir
complètement et simplement essayer de
garder une distance avec son numérique
avec les informations qu'on va relayer
sur nous sur ce que nous sommes en tant
qu'individu ça permet de se prémunir un
petit peu en tout cas elle rester assez
vigilant ça permet de se prémunir un
tout petit peu de cette surveillance
croisé réciproque et constante que nous
impose le numérique pour finir
j'aimerais vous diriger vers une série
et vers une lecture donc la série il
s'agit donc de black mirror qui est une
série dystopique qui va en fait traiter
de différents sujets liés au numérique
il ya nos pratiques numériques est liée
à ce que pourrait être finalement notre
société si toutes ces logiques du mien
qui étaient poussés à leur paroxysme et
notamment le premier épisode de la
saison 3 reprend cette idée comme si on
avait un notation à l'albert un petit
peu et dont tous les aspects de notre
vie et ça c'est assez intéressant dans
la mesure où on va faire quoi cela
pourrait mener et c'est assez éclairant
du coup c'est assez effrayant mais celle
ci est assez éclairant sur sur ce que
nos sociétés pourraient devenir avec le
contrôle croisé lié aux algues au rythme
et au numérique
en second lieu j'aimerais vous
conseiller la lecture d'un article de
viviane que l'on peut trouver sur persia
je crois qu'il s'appelle la télévision
surveillance enjeux du panneau petit sme
les dispositifs de la télé réalité qui
prend un peu long et qu'un qui est très
intéressant de ce qu'ils voient en quoi
la téléréalité est une forme
particulière de panneaux petit sme et en
quoi le numérique pourrait finalement
nous amener à considérer cette
surveillance que mes services légitime
et naturelle voilà donc c'est fini pour
ce second épisode j'espère qu'il vous a
plu et j'espère que ça va vous un petit
peu éclairé sur l'idée du panoptique
j'aimerais également remercier nota bene
il ya une chaîne histoire était très
près cool qui a relayé ma vidéo là pour
la première vidéo ont beaucoup changé
mais également le remercier des roses
est peut-être la grâce à lui dans ce cas
là j'espère que vous paiera également la
troisième vidéo est déjà en cours
d'écriture et donc du coup elle devrait
également pas tarder à arriver
en attendant je vous souhaite une
superbe journée soit réuni tout ce que
vous voulez et je vous dis à très
bientôt
salut cours
on
[Musique]